tu es à l'article 24 l'amendement 21
présenté par madame fournier ainsi que
l'amendement 22 puisque tous deux font
l'objet d'une discussion commune
vous avez la parole pour ces deux
amendements chers collègues eh bien
écoutez je l'ait déjà évoqué dans la
discussion générale
cet amendement propose de réécrire
l'article l 121 4 du code de
l'environnement du code de l'urbanisme
pardon afin de rétablir une égalité de
droit simplement entre les ports les
aérodromes et la liaison fixe
transmanche la rédaction en vigueur du
dit article ne mentionne pas la liaison
fixe qui se trouve de fait exclus du
régime der goot dérogatoire pour
octroyer au port et aérodromes pardon
l'article 24 propose du projet de loi
limite la régularisation des
installations de la liaison fixe aux
seules installations constructions et
aménagements nécessaires au lien fixe
transmanche dans le cadre du
rétablissement des contrôles de
marchandises et des passagers à
destination et en provenance du royaume
uni en raison du retrait de cette étape
bref en raison du break site uniquement
et tout ça lève en fait un problème qui
est récurrent en fait avec la liaison
fixe transmanche c'est qu'en fait ils
sont exclus du droit commun à chaque
fois ce que je demande simplement avec
cet amendement c'est qu'ils soient
traités de la même manière que le sont
les ports de calais boulogne et les
aéroports éventuellement la liaison fixe
transmanche n'est pas une liaison et je
le disais tout à l'heure
simple c'est en fait de ce sont des
navettes donc qu'ils sont qui remplace
les bateaux qui charge des camions avec
du fret des véhicules de tourisme des
bus et qui permet aussi
mais parallèlement le passage direct de
l'eurostar donc pourquoi appliquer une
différence pourquoi ne pas profiter de
cet événement pour lever cette
incertitude et répondre à tout cela
vous savez ce sont les deux amendements
le premier
je vous le présente et je le
maintiendrai le second ce sera un
amendement de repli
voilà ce que je voulais dire c'est que
ce lien fixe transmanche c'est un des
premiers employeurs privés de notre
territoire
il emploie 1700 personnes et 4500
emplois sont induits par toutes les
activités qu'il génère alors s'il vous
plaît pensons à ces salariés j'ai reçu
également les syndicats et je pense
qu'il est important aujourd'hui de se
poser les bonnes questions pourquoi
différencier les deux régimes
alors que de toute façon la loi
urbanisme
elle est la même le tunnel sous la
manche ne peut pas se déplacer il est
sur la zone côtière
il va pas aller réaliser des
infrastructures à 100 kilomètres de chez
lui c'est pas possible on il a la même
gestion que les aéroports et voilà tout
simplement ce que je vous demande par
ses amendements
voilà merci merci alors monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission sur
ces deux à mon nom
merci merci madame la sénatrice pour
déjà défense des amendements et puis
également pour comment dire l'exposé que
vous avez bien voulu faire au début de
séance donc on a bien compris les enjeux
et aux préoccupations et j'espère que
l'argumentaire vous satisfera l'avis est
défavorable pour deux raisons sur
l'opportunité de codifier ces
dispositions dans le code de l'urbanisme
il est vrai que conseil d'état soulève
ce point dans son avis dans un souci de
lisibilité du droit toutefois il me
semble qu'en l'espèce la codification
n'est pas opportune compte tenu de la
nature des dispositions en effet
l'article 24 un objet très strictes 1 il
vise uniquement régulariser les
installations construites au niveau du
lien fixe transmanche pour tenir compte
du rétablissement des contrôles à la
suite du break 6 pts en pratique il
s'agit donc uniquement de permettre la
délivrance d'un permis de construire a
posteriori et - aucun cas de créer des
possibilités d'aménagements futurs sur
le fond cet amendement vise à produire
une dérogation à la loi littoral au
bénéfice du site
eurotunnel je n'y suis pas favorable
pour trois raisons d'abord il me semble
que l'amendement proposé porte une
atteinte forte à la loi littoral
il est vrai que des assouplissements la
loi littoral ont été décidées ces
dernières années par législateur
notamment à travers la loi élan en 2018
qui a autorisé des opérations visant à
combler les dents creuses en dehors des
villages et agglomérations
toutefois en l'espèce il s'agissait de
permettre la densification des espaces
creux situés dans des zones déjà
urbanisées l'atteinte portée à la loi
littoral et aux principes d'organisation
continuité les constructions existence
était donc plus limité la loi littoral
repose sur la recherche d'un équilibre
entre les principes les impératifs de
protection de l'environnement et
d'aménagement et il me semble que
l'espèce l'equilibre proposé par
l'amendement n'est pas satisfaisant
d'autre part si je comprends les enjeux
économiques sont soulevés en matière de
concurrence entre les modes de transport
il me semble difficile de mettre les
ports comme le port de calais et
l'eurotunnel sur le même plan en matière
de préservation du littoral car ils sont
pas soumis au même statut juridique le
port rollup domaine public
autrement dit les autorités publiques
disposent d'un moyen de contrôle des
décisions d'aménagement qui sont prises
ce qui n'est pas le cas de l'eurotunnel
qui est une entité privée
si nous introduisons une directive à la
loi littoral pour le lien transmanche
transmanche
nous exposons donc potentiellement une
zone littorale sensible à un risque
d'étalement des constructions en dehors
de tout contrôle de l'état
cela ne me semble pas souhaitable enfin
je tiens à souligner que le terminal
d'eurotunnel les installations connexes
ont situé à la limite des communes de
coquelles et fréthun qui ne sont pas
soumises à la loi littoral
il existe donc déjà des possibilités
d'extension des installations
d'eurotunnel sans déroger à la loi
littoral la vie et donc défavorable pour
l'amendement au numéro 22 a rectifié la
vie est également défavorable pour les
mêmes raisons que l'amendement précédent
introduit une telle dérogation d'un code
de l'urbanisme porte une atteinte à la
loi littoral qui me semble
disproportionné
la question soulevée par cet amendement
est toutefois intéressante
d'après les éléments que j'ai pu
rassembler eurotunnel risque de faire
face à un besoin nouveau en matière
d'aménagement dans un futur proche
notamment du fait de l'entrée en vigueur
de la réglementation européenne
européenne entrée existe système qui
imposera de nouvelles obligations en
matière de sûreté et de sécurité dès
2022 la vie et donc défavorable mais je
souhaite donc que le gouvernement nous
fournisse des éléments sur la manière
dont il entend permettre à eurotunnel de
s'adapter à des contraintes et besoins
qui pourraient survenir dans le futur
y compris à très court terme si l'avis
du gouvernement madame la ministre je
répondrais également sur c'est sur ces
deux amendements madame la sénatrice
fournier on gère un cas ici qui est tout
à fait particulier exceptionnel vous
l'aurez compris avec cette cette
codification de la disposition relative
à la régularisation des aménagements
liés au brésil dans le tunnel sous la
manche est et l'élargissement de son
champ d'application
cet article 24 il introduit une
dérogation aux dispositions du code de
l'urbanisme
issu de la loi littoral le rapporteur la
l'a rappelé dont bénéficient déjà les
installations nécessaires au
fonctionnement de services publics
portuaires mais nous avons ici dû
permettre à eurotunnel de pouvoir
déposer un permis de construire de
régulation des infrastructures de
contrôle frontalier qui sont existantes
si j'ose dire il fallait absolument
régulariser des installations déjà
construites en sait dans quel contexte
mais surtout pas étendre de manière
pérenne cette cette dérogation
qui n'ont qu'un caractère tout à fait
ponctuel
c'est donc un avis défavorable sur les
deux amendements puisque quel que soit
le mode de codification ce cet
argumentaire demeure merci oui église de
même fourni il monsieur corbizet votre
alors je reprends ce que disait monsieur
le rapporteur loi littoral vous parliez
monsieur le rapporteur d'une atteinte
forte
pourquoi le permettre au port et ne pas
le permettre à eurotunnel le plus gros
concurrent sur la place c'est eurotunnel
au niveau des ports que ce soit boulogne
calais donc ça c'est une évidence
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi on ferait
une différenciation entre le port sec
que l'on appelle d'ailleurs comme ça sur
notre territoire et le port maritime
sincèrement je ne la comprends pas je
comprends pas l'argument alors recherche
d'un équilibre
vous l'avez pas vous l'avais dit c'était
une des raisons qui qui vous faisait me
de me donner un avis négatif
alors pour moi vous savez l'equilibre
c'est cloyes c'est quoi c'est du
développement durable il repose sur
trois piliers
il repose sur le social l'économique et
l'environnement je vois pas en quoi ce
cette proposition d'amendement ne
respectent pas cette ce droit
environnement alors vous parliez des
ports et des aéroports qu'eurotunnel
était une société privée sous concession
d'état je vous le précise d'accord une
concession d'état qui a été reportée qui
était à l'origine sur 50 ans donc je ne
vois pas je ne comprends pas les
arguments
vous parliez madame la ministre d'un cas
exceptionnel mais bien sûr c'était le
plus gros chantier du siècle dernier le
plus gros chantier financiers alors s'il
vous plaît donnez nous les ambitions de
ce chantier préservons l'activité
économique qu'il a créé sur notre
territoire et ne créons pas une
différence est une discrimination entre
le port maritime et le port sec
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire je
maintiens mes deux amendements j'espère
que le premier passera si monsieur
corbisez
oui j'aime a expliqué à mes collègues
est aussi sénateur du pas de calais je
comprends pas il ya contradiction entre
à la fois une atteinte à la loi littoral
et en même temps on continue et va
devoir s'adapter très prochainement à
des voiles de sûreté ou de sécurité
bon au demandent une régularisation par
rapport aux briques site et en même
temps je m'étonne qu'on pourrait mettre
atteinte à la loi littoral dans le sens
où le lien transmanche il à l'endroit où
il est actuellement
et là où est donc à délocalisables
qu'entre la pénétration des trains dans
le sous-sol dans le tunnel pour passer
sous la manche et le bord de mer il y à
plus de deux kilomètres donc en quoi
eurotunnel il reste se rapprocher du
littoral et mettre à mal à louer tu
râles
d'autant plus que dans ce secteur-là
d'entre le cap gris nez le cap blanc-nez
la plupart des terrains en bord de mer
appartiennent ou au conseil département
du pas de calais ou à eden 62
quand je le vois pas comment une
structure privée pourra les racheter des
terres déjà protégée auprès d'une
collectivité territoriale comme le
conseil départemental du pas de calais
et donc à banon on parle de sûreté et
qui a valu moment par rapport aux
briques site
la société a déjà mis en place des
structures ont renforcé la sécurité des
séquelles donc elle a déjà anticipé ce
que monsieur leur apportera 10 sur
l'augmentation de son rôle de ceux sur
qui à partir de 2022 donc qu'est ce que
ça coûte aujourd'hui de donner un avis
une structure qui commun permet
aujourd'hui d'aller en angleterre par
mauvais temps parce que quand on dit the
six moderate sur général vous balader
sacs en papier devant le nez alors
qu'avec le lien transmanche
on est quand même les pieds au sec et je
vois pas en quoi on pourrait toucher me
protège les attaques et le litre alors
qu'il est déjà protégé le conseil
général département du pas de calais et
je vois pas pourquoi on ne pourrait pas
validé les structures de sûreté qui ont
déjà été anticipées
moi je serais favorable à le moment d'un
fournier merci alors je vais m on voit
l'amendement 21 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas